comment allez-vous aujourd'hui on va
parler de ma corde sensible
on a tous une sensibilité différente et
on est tous plus ou moins sensibles à
des sujets différents ya par exemple des
gens qui sont super émue quand il voit
un bébé qui s'amuse avec un jouet et
d'autres qui sont émus des vidéos où
c'est des retrouvailles au sein d'une
famille aujourd'hui on va parler d'une
de mes deux cordes sensibles qui sont
les vidéos ou des personnes âgées sont
émus bah j'ai envie de chialer
directement j'ai envie d'aller en ai pas
dit de faire des câlins tout le monde
d'accord il diffuse et ils diffusent le
litre chaque semaine je vous jure ça me
fait vraiment un truc c'est terrible ça
tous qu'en janvier je vais moto émouvoir
j'aime regarder dans la glace et chiale
ray ma deuxième corde sensible et l'aele
et ultime c'est les vidéos d'animaux les
vidéos par exemple un chien retrouve ses
maîtres après s'être perdu pendant 6
mois ou quelqu'un recueille en écureuil
mal en point ils deviennent meilleurs
potes dans le genre il ya la chaîne the
dodos dont j'ai déjà parlé dans
plusieurs vidéos vous la connaissez
probablement céder vidéo de sauvetage
d'animaux au début tu vois un animal
vraiment mal en point il récupère il
apprivoise peu à peu il se met à leur
faire confiance et à la fin de la vidéo
il est resplendissant voilà elle me met
tellement mal ces vidéos que maintenant
quand je la regarde je fais d avance
rapide c'est je clique à plein
d'endroits différents la vidéo pour
juste la voir en express sinon je suis
trop triste c'est grave ça va pas du
tout bref on va parler de trois
histoires qui sont semblables à celles
de chico l'histoire la plus connue d'un
animal qui est in love avec son maître
l'histoire date chico je vous la résume
en trois phrases idée sabour ueno aller
au travail chaque matin donc ils se
rendent à la gare de shibuya et son ac
ita l'accompagner à chico et retourner
passer la journée à la maison et puis en
fin d'après midi chaque jour et
retourner tout seul à la gare pour
retrouver son maître qui rentrait du
travail
malheureusement en mai 1925 à chico en
fin d'après-midi et devant la gare comme
tous les jours il attend le retour de
son maître
sauf que ce jour là son maître ne va pas
revenir du travail puisqu'il est décédé
d'une hémorragie intracérébrale sur son
lieu de travail la famille des idées
sabouraud renault et s'est trouvé une
nouvelle famille à hachiko sauf que
systématiquement il s'enfuit et y
retourne au domicile de son ancien
maître et chaque fin d'après midi ils
seront à la gare de shibuya dans
l'espoir de voir son maître sortir de la
gare et pouvoir rentrer à la maison avec
lui les jours passent les semaines
passent et tous les jours à la même
heure à chico et devant la gare de
shibuya attendre son maître dix ans
après en mars 1935 à chico décède et la
truc un peu glauque qu'ils ont pris ces
restes et ils l'ont employé si vous
allez au musée national de la nature et
des sciences de tokyo vous pourrez voir
le vrai
hachiko totalement mort en paille et le
reste de sa dépouille a été enterré au
cimetière d'awoingt yamaha côté de la
tombe de son maître et cette histoire
est devenue tellement mythique un des
spots les plus connus de tokyo c'est une
statue date chico qui est juste devant
la gare de shibuya là où il attendait
son maître du coup dans les années 20
bref je vous ai résumé l'histoire si
vous voulez en savoir plus et voir une
très belle offre
il ya le film hachey qui retrace cette
histoire là mais malheureusement vu que
j'ai une corde très sensée à ce sujet
j'ai toujours refusé de le voir je vais
déprimé pendant dix jours et collez
natsu chaque seconde de ma vie jusqu'à
la fin dans le même genre la première
histoire dont je vous parlais c'est
celle de john hunger aide son chien
chouette cette histoire elle a fait le
tour du monde et elle s'est fait
connaître grâce à un cliché de chouette
avec son maître dans l'eau et l'histoire
est aussi ouf que la photo en 1993
schoepp est un chien battu en très
mauvais état et les recueillis par john
et sa fiancée alors qu'il a seulement
huit mois 19 ans plus tard c'est énorme
pour un chien john apprend que shu et
souffre d'une arthrose énervé et que
donc il souffre il a extrêmement mal et
qu'il faudrait donc pas tarder à baugé
ses souffrances et à l'euthanasie
john il apprend ça il est dévastée pour
lui c'est hors de question d'euthanasie
et son chien comme ça parce qu'ils
souffrent et décide plutôt de mener un
combat contre la souffrance de son chien
et c'est là qu'il a une idée
la thérapie aquatique et l'emmène choix
polak le plus proche de chez lui
et devinez quoi ça marche tellement que
chouette s'endort dans les bras de son
maître john il est trop content de
pouvoir offrir ça à son chien et du coup
il va faire ça tous les jours et tous
les jours chouette va s'endormir dans
les bras de john tellement ça lui fait
du bien
la photo que je vous ai montré c'est une
photo qui a été prise par une amie de
john hannah qui est venu un jour au lac
en 2013
extrait pour prendre des photos de john
et de son chien en souvenir pour lui en
fait elles vont publier une et la giga
buzz
des centaines de milliers de personnes
vont apporter leur soutien à john et
voit aller jusqu'à lui proposer de
financer les soins médicaux de chopes
s'il y en a besoin
malheureusement il n'y a rien à faire je
sois pas 19 ans un moment tu peux pas
lutter contre la vieillesse tout ce que
je peux faire c'est continuer de
l'emmener au lac pour le soulager et
gratter quelques moments avec son animal
apaisé qui s'endort dans ses bras avant
que malheureusement ils partent au ciel
je suis pas bien je vous raconte
l'histoire je suis pas bien même ce
qu'on patcher aérien vous soyez pas bien
ça me touche trop je casse l'ambiance
chouette meurt en juillet 2013 de
vieillesse
après une longue et magnifique vie
évidemment john et dévasté son camarade
lui manquer
remerciera jamais assez pour tout ce qui
lui a apporté et aussi fait un message
aux internautes pour les remercier parce
qu'il a été vachement touché de recevoir
autant d'amour et le message john a mis
quelques années à faire son deuil et il
a ensuite décidé d'adopter
pire il a posté une photo de lui aux
côtés de son chien sur facebook avec en
légende
je me sens de nouveau entier les gars en
fait je suis trop émus de la dévolution
de ce mec envers son animal de compagnie
c'est incroyable il donne tout pour son
animal et ça se voit sur visage son
animal ceux qui sont pas trop touchés
par les animaux qui sont pas très
sensible à ce sujet là il n'y a aucun
problème y en a probablement beaucoup je
suis sûr que ça vous a un peu touché
gabon deuxième histoire c'est l'aele et
abuser ça se passe en russie et donc il
n'est pas question d'un chien mais tu as
donc oui c'est bon c'est l'histoire de
andré et de manceaux cette histoire est
devenu très connu en russie elle a
énormément tourné et paraît elle aimait
cas touchant un jour à l'aérodrome dans
l'autre cas à 168 km au nord ouest de
moscou
les employés aperçoivent un ourson
personne ne sait ce qu'il fout là
puisque c'est pas du tout un endroit où
il ya des sources qui passe mais il est
là quoi qu'il en soit il est assez mal
en point il a très peur et il a très
faim bref les employés aperçoive
et là ils vont leur est égal et îlots
réchauffe et lui donne à manger et lui
donne un nom manceau il adore les
humains et les humains l'adorent eelv
est un peu l'animal de compagnie tout le
monde et particulièrement un pilote de
l'aérodrome qui s'appelle andré ivanoff
lui c'est un beau gosse il sait qu'en
face de lui il a un ourson c'est pas un
chien c'est pas un chat ce pas un animal
domestique c'est un animal sauvage qui a
un instinct et et commence à se
renseigner pour savoir comment faire
pour mettre au mieux cet ourson le
remettent dans la nature en fête dans
son habitat naturel sauf que m'en sors
il est trop petit et va se faire
défoncer normalement à un ourson comme
pour tous les animaux bébé si la mer les
plus là pour le protéger les débats il
meurt il peut pas s'en sortir seul du
commanderie va s'occuper de lui pendant
plusieurs mois mansur devient un jeune
adulte et la andré contacter une
association qui est spécialisé dans le
fait de recueillir des animaux de leur
apprendre à chasser à se protéger à à
construire un nid savais pas que ça
existait des cours particuliers pour ce
sacré métier malheureusement
l'association elle explique à andré que
mensonge il a passé trop temps avec des
humains du coup il a perdu ses instincts
y compris la peur de l'homme et angoua
et lui explique voilà si le remède dans
son habitat naturel
à un moment il va s'éloigner il va
arriver dans un village mansoura la
recherche du main parce qu'il kiffe les
humains sous qui va tomber sur des
chasseurs et il va se faire buter andreï
l'edhec évidemment il se creuse la tête
et se dit mais vas-y jeu
trop lui offrir la meilleure vie douce
possible à ces sources je veux qu'ils
mangent du poisson à foison qu'il a une
copine ours
il prend vraiment à coeur les choses et
là il se dit tout de suite mais attends
j'ai calmé dans une réserve naturelle
d'ours et il va être trop bien le rêve
d'un grand terrain des copains ours de
la nourriture à volonté tout en étant
protégé par l'humain le kiff de fil en
aiguille il obtient numéro d'une
personne qui connaît bien une réserve
naturelle d'ours
quelques semaines plus tard les gens
arrivent à l'aérodrome ils viennent pour
récupérer mon souhait est le maître
direct dans une toute petite cage
rouillée
en plus de ça les mecs sont pas très
poli il discute pas et viennent il le
mettre dans la cage et merci au revoir
voilà ça dégage et la andriy ivanov il a
un instinct paternel mon pote paternelle
envers un ours
il enquête et découvre que au bout du
chemin la voiture n'a pas pris la
direction de la réserve naturelle pour
ce qui situe à plusieurs heures de route
évidemment mais a pris la direction
opposée
étrange pourquoi les jours qui suivent
andré continue de creuser et continue
d'enquêter et tous les employés de
l'aérodrome en quête aussi il kiffe
manceau vraiment c'est leur bébé est là
il découvre qu'en fait il a été emmené
dans un centre d'entraînement de chasse
andré réussi à se procurer l'adresse du
camp en question et se ruent là-bas en
caisse en arrivant il est rassuré mansur
et dans sa cage il a maigri il a le poil
dégueulasse évidemment il n'était pas du
tout bien traités et lui rendent mansur
et lui faire mes gars calme andré il a
expliqué que mansour est venu vers lui
et lui a attrapé légende en mode
qu'alinghi se frotter et où moi j'aurais
très peur à sa place il va donc ouvrir
une cagnotte destinée à construire un
enclos de ouf comme dans les réserves
naturelles pour mansour et devinez quoi
la cagnotte cartonne l'emploi est
construit montsouris vie enfin dans un
truc digne d'un ours adultes et andré et
tout le staff qui bosse à l'aérodrome et
sont trop contents aussi mansur devinez
quoi il refuse de manger du poisson et
de la viande et mangent que des fruits
des légumes et des oeufs
il est végétarien cet ours on dirait une
blague andré y racontaient qu'ils jouent
avec lui et quand il devient un peu de
ces genres trop nerveux et du coup ça
peut être dangereux parce que clairement
signes de mort un peu trop fort lourd
sbata plus demain il le prive
d'attention genre ils le voient pas de
l'après midi heymans ou alors s'ils
comprenaient du coup après ce qu'on
portait à carreaux c'est génial depuis
andré van hove il continue de prendre
soin de ma souris lui rend visite
régulièrement à l'histoire a fait le
tour de la russie de la cagnotte
continue de grimper du coup l'argent
sert à aménager mieux l'enclos est la
même pour remercier les gens et
l'entretien cette cagnotte fait un live
24 24 grâce à une caméra qui l'a mis
dans l'enclos de manseau et du coup tu
le vois hiberner tu vois se balader qui
fait c'est vraiment marrant
évidemment on va faire un petit tour sur
live
et on veut le voir madame ans au ces on
ne peut plus décevant mais là en fait je
pense qu'il vit berne
on a en février donc à mon avis il est
juste en train de dormir tout le temps
auto poule cleaning système hockey du
coup là les dons serviront à acheter un
système de nettoyage automatique de sa
piscine
il a un meilleur niveau de vie que nous
cet ours c'est incroyable il ya plein
d'histoires comme ça où des animaux
sauvages qui ont donc un instinct de ouf
donc ils ont peur des humains et c'est
pour survivre qu'ils ont peur des
humains que l'humain est un de
prédateurs pour eux maintenant certains
cas l'animal sauvage y perd quand même
son instinct et kiffe les humains je
vois des vidéos les gens ils sont potes
avec des renards pincer c'est improbable
sauce avons une option une tradition qui
nous amène tout droit vers notre
troisième histoire celle de loki mecs
n'ont pas le personnel ventures que moi
j'adore mais que pas grand monde m mélo
qui le corbeau celui qui te voler ton
sandwich triangle quand tu prenais à
poser au parc lui aimait clokey en 2018
c'est un corbeau domestique
il s'est fait domestique et je sais pas
comment je sais pas pourquoi mais il est
domestique du coup ils adorent les
humains bref lyon qui en 2018 il se
retrouve seul suite au décès de son
propriétaire
il est en dépression et voit un psy il
est pas bien y avoir marqué ça dans
l'article je savais pas que les corbeaux
pouvait faire des dépressions bref
elliott le recueil dans son refuge et
ils découvrent un animal cammas
affection pour les humains il le décrit
comme un chien dans un corps de corbeau
c'est bon et elliot il nous régale parce
qu'il a alimentés sont installés sont
youtube de plein de vidéos de l'eau qui
est effectivement c'est ouf
regardez-moi ça quand il est content il
fait comme les chiens il remue la queue
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bordel dans
ma rue à paris il ya tout en plein de
cambo c'est pas des loups qui met qu'un
regardez-moi ça il ya tellement une
brome ans entre elliott et loki qui lui
offre de cadeaux de noël et que l'eau
qu'ils aient des balles directement je
suis à deux doigts de chalais il
est content mais qu il eut au revoir la
balle comme un chien c'est n'importe
quoi et il joue avec le de
conques 1 jouets pour chiens
là vous commencez à l'aimer score bourg
et vous êtes surpris l'heure de
commencer à avoir d'affection pour
encore vous attendez il y en a qui font
de la musique lacombe besoin d'une
petite crotte de papa
pour le stimuler il le fait jouer qu'un
exil au fon et ils jouent une note
et si l'eau qui appuie sur la même note
il lui donne à manger c'est fou je lui
seul est passionné par ce de
corbeaux mais attention l'eau qui fait
aussi des bêtises
ici il a volé mouassa d'or et 1
il faut supporter les matches car sachez
que l'eau qui est tellement un gros
beauf que vous pouvez jouer aux jeux de
société avec nous vous pouvez par
exemple faire une petite partie de
ouistitis et il est plutôt bon en plus
en vrai c'est trop stylé ce qui fait les
lionnes et il trouve des petits
mécanismes pour stimuler faire kiffer
l'eau qui il faut faire ça avec vos
chiens il ya plein de jouer comme ça
d'ailleurs pour chien qui les stimulent
intellectuellement et moi natsu et
profondément idiot d'accord c'est un
grand complexe que j'ai je lui en achète
les trucs les plus évolués style et où
100% de réussite
il teste et après ils abandonnent direct
il est vraiment comme moi c'est
incroyable
messieurs dames c'est la fin de cette
vidéo bon vous l'avez compris -
clairement des des humains qui s'occupe
avec passion d'animaux sa moue touch2 ya
plein plein plein de vidéos de jean
quête des animaux qui les sauve qui les
soignent et je trouve ça magnifique
voilà bref je suis content de voir
parler de ces trois histoires aurais-je
le courage après cette vidéo de regarder
enfin hachey non non merci d'avoir
regardé tout au moins une petite photo
de vous et de votre animal en mode
qu'alain d'amour
on l'avait déjà fait une fois en story
j'avais adoré là je vais vous dire je
sais ce que vous allez faire la caresser
votre chat ou votre chien et moi aussi
aller à tout
[Musique]